so
hello everybody
thank you any questions i'll be
available later um
my name is john hann i work for a
company called pivotal
you probably know us for some product or
some service or some division of us
somewhere
i am the resident javascript barbarian
figure out what that means on your own
actually i work for pivotal's frameworks
and runtimes department
one of the many departments and these
are some of the projects that we work on
within the frameworks and runtimes
department
i'm very proud of these all open source
there's lots of other ones private
source private
products and whatnot and specifically uh
what i work on on a day to day basis is
the cujo js toolkit so
you may have encountered one of these um
in your travels or in your programming
endeavors
um so but anyways i'm not here to talk
about any of that stuff i'm here to talk
about javascript of course because
javascript is
awesome and that's why we're all here uh
and actually javascript has become
incredibly sophisticated i mean we all
know that's why we're here today
you know we're doing all sorts of crazy
things that a couple years ago nobody
thought we were going to be doing you
know
we're doing aop we do dependency
inversion and version of control
we do have all sorts of crazy
architectures um
we're doing things with other languages
transpiling to them
uh integrating with things like you know
obviously it's a multi-language
environment in the browser we got html
css all this stuff we've got package
managers now
uh you know we've got minim fires
optimizers builds
you know which really um
was a wtf for me but anyways with this
sophistication
you know comes more complexity and of
course more machinery you got to set up
all this stuff you got to configure all
this stuff
and when you configure all the stuff now
you've got a maintenance task you've got
a whole new
sub project just to have a javascript
based project
and this is what i mean when i realized
that
that the good old days are gone and we
can't just you know
add a script tag to a minimal html file
you know and now we have to actually you
know build stuff in order to have an
application that was a big wtf so what
happened to the good old days what
happened when we could just do this
we could just add a script tag maybe a
style sheet and just get started coding
you know if you want to do a quick
prototype
you know this is what you did you just
you know you just quickly created an
html page
created a javascript page linked them
together and then just started coding
right
so you know now if you actually want to
do that in order to do that you kind of
have to write crappy code that's my
opinion of course you know but
um but if you really wanted to to
prototype something and you want to do
it in an architecturally sound way you
want to do it with your favorite
uh framework or you just want to
incorporate some you know of the
the current best practices you can't
just get started like that anymore
so in order to do it the right way you
either have to have lots of boilerplate
lots of configuration lots of machinery
and and it's just too much work in
general um and in my day job
you know we were we're encountering
countering this problem trying to create
tutorials
one part of my part of my job
description is to create tutorials so
that the java folks out there can learn
how to use javascript and that's as an
impossible task on its own but then on
top of that
if you have to you know you have to
explain to them okay
first you have to set up your your grunt
file your gulp file and then oh yeah
you want to use amd you know i set up
your amd config and stuff it's just it's
just way too much stuff you can't
you can't quickly you know you can't get
someone to the meat of the problem quick
enough now because
configuration is too too complex
so here's just a quick example this is
an actual project that i was asked to
consult
for um they started out with a 500 line
grunt file
and we said whoa whoa whoa this is way
too much you guys have to be doing
something wrong
right so we went in there and we looked
and first thing we said ah
you know you guys need to choose a
module system all this global stuff you
know
number one you shouldn't be using
globals anymore and b
this is going to cut out so much of your
grunt file it only cut out 100 lines of
the grunt file
and then of course they ended up having
to have an amd config file which was 70
lines of code so
so here's the grunt file right here um
uh
yeah so this is this is a grub file and
this is all you know they did the
research this is the best practices
stuff you know they're minifying all the
things
you know they're they're using less and
and pre-processing it
um you know here's their you know
main.js so that they can they can have
amd
modules in in the browser
and then there can you know the testing
config you know then they had to have
testing config
and this is actually the pare down
testing config that they had so
so can we simplify this mess um
and my answer is yes we we need to and
if you've been coding in java recently i
know if anybody has but you know this
this code that i'm showing up here
reminds me a lot of
you know maven code or xml files all the
stuff that
you used to have to do in java and i say
used to because
there's some new projects out there one
of them from pivotal spring boot
which eliminates all of it so you you
basically have no more xml no more you
know configuration you just get started
and so
you know my bosses come to me and say
what the hell why do we have to do this
stuff in javascript still so
so now my job is to to try to eliminate
all this configuration mess that we have
to do in javascript so
that's where rave comes in so what is
rave i'll tell you right now it's not a
new framework you're not
not a rave global you're going to code
too you don't have to require rave in
your code
actually we're not going to touch your
code at all so it's not another loader
it's not
not an amd loader but it does have a
loader built in actually it has an es6
style loader
and it uses a shim built by guy bedford
who's here somewhere so
pat him on the back next time you see
him he's doing an excellent job
on an es6 loader shim so it use it's
built for the future
you can load things like amd you can
load common jazz
uh pretty soon you'll be able to load
es6 and rave and you can load other
things too a lot of things you're used
to loading
if you're using amd now you can load css
text json whatever
but unfortunately it's not ready for
production yet you know you can play
with it now
and we have gotten probably about a
third of the way to where we want to be
and at about two-thirds of the way we're
going to say yes this is ready for you
to use so probably about another four to
six weeks
um i'm going to try to get it in less
than that but let's see and we want your
feedback that's why i'm here today i
want feedback i want you guys to come
tell me and say this sucks you know
this is not the way we want to do things
and and we're going to try to
accommodate you
and accommodate people that maybe love
it so
okay so what are we trying to do in free
bullets
provided default you know instantly out
of the box
configuration you install rave bag
you've got something to run you've got
an app it's a simple app it's just
it's basically a hello world app um but
you've got something and you can just
immediately start
start doing something make it easy then
to get
sophisticated you know start doing
things like
the advanced testing install your
favorite favorite framework
start doing transpiling and that kind of
stuff make it brain dead easy to start
doing that
and then make it easy to assert your own
opinion again we don't wanna
you know we have to impose some opinion
but we want that to be extremely minimal
so um one of the ways to
get a default you know runnable
configuration
is through something called a rave
starter and basically it's just a repo
on github you just go and
you you download it and you just you
know follow the instructions it's very
simple instructions just
then launch your favorite browser open
up your favorite editor id and you get
started but there's also a way to start
from scratch and if i have some time i'm
going to show you
both methods actually how to start from
scratch just by
typing in npm init or bowering it and
starting from there
so the way this works the reason there's
no build step is because the run time
by default is responsive to the
environment and actually auto you know
auto configs based off things it can
find
um through the browser and so you get
you're in this mode and if you're used
to
um require js and amd you just write
code reload
you know repeat you know write some code
reload write some code reload there's no
build steps
in the default amd configuration so
we've reproduced that
but in a much more sophisticated way
so if you want to get sophisticated we
wanted to be a one-liner
very easy to move over to now you're
building
and then you know of course when you're
building now you've got
file watchers you've got pre-processes
you get transpilers you've got
you've got you know bundlers and
builders and all the sophisticated stuff
and that comes with source maps and all
this all these
things that could go wrong so so we want
it easy to go
back again and and and you'll be able to
go back
and forth and back and forth into
whatever mode you want to and still
zero configuration and then of course
tests we want it to be brain dead easy
to start test we're not going to write
your tests for you
yet but um but obviously you know
testing has got to be an important part
of the strategy
so when you want to assert your opinion
of course we're not going to tell you
what to write we're not we're not going
to write your app code for you that's up
to you
but if you decide that you want to use
angular we want you to be able to just
bang
one line you're starting to use angular
if you want to do something crazy like
this
i don't know if something like this
exists but you want to use knockout and
backbone together i don't know if that
could even happen
but if you wanted to we wanted to make
possible for someone
out there to create what we're calling a
rave integration package
to allow someone who's figured out how
to make it work
to just push that out onto the web and
then you can pull that down and use it
so then if you want to add other
capabilities like
browser capabilities you want to start
using web components
or you want to you know start loading
using the loader to load things that
besides just modules
you can do that as well and of course we
want this to work in multiple
environments
so spring and rails are the ones that
internally we need to get working so
okay so how can this possibly work and
the answer is through metadata
so we're going to by default if you
install a starter
we're going to provide a minimal amount
of metadata for you already and this
metadata is going to be in bower.json or
package.json
and then if you knew it or not you're
already generating metadata
so for instance every time you you do a
bower install you've pulled some more
data
metadata down with that package or
anytime you do npm install you're
pulling down
additional metadata and all you have to
do is is include the dash dash
save if i everybody look at the dash
dash save okay do we see the dash dash
save if as long as you do that
you've pulled the metadata in a way
that's now discoverable
and it's discoverable without searching
your file system so that's very
important for
you know for rave to be able to auto
discover you know that
for it to be responsive to the
environment
and then as i mentioned before people
will be able to create these integration
packets so you could just do bower
install
or npm install my favorite integration
package that pulls this this and this
together and install it and that comes
with
additional metadata and and actually
there's an opportunity to
pull an additional glue code as well at
that point
so other rave extensions we actually
have a number of extensions out there
already we've got um
12 or 14 extensions out on on npm and
bauer at the moment
so you know of course you'll be able to
you know
install some crazy integration package
we have
we have a rave angular package out there
already
we've got we've actually started work on
a polymer package
and actually most of the ones on the
screen don't exist yet but they will
soon
so then you know what's the easiest way
to allow a developer what is the one
liner that someone needs to type in
order to make this work so we're
thinking okay so we could create a brave
cli and that's a that's an interesting
idea with the rave cli we can remove the
guesswork
uh we can we can do a lot of intelligent
things because right now
you know if if if you're mixing npm and
bauer which is possible with rave you
know you can get yourself into these
really nasty situations
um so we're thinking about a rave cli
and you know that's one way to do it but
we also at the same time
you know we don't want to get in your
way we don't want you to have yet
another cli if you don't want it so
anything we do will also be possible
with the command lines you're used to
npm
gulp grunt and bauer
okay so this is the part where i'm going
to attempt to do
a little bit of coding and show you what
this is
like okay
and my cheat sheet has disappeared
okay
all right so just uh to try and
illustrate how simple this
is supposed to be can everybody see that
fine that
terminal window do i need to up that
how's that is that good all right so i'm
gonna make a directory and i'm going to
cd into it okay so this is this is the
bootstrap case where you're just going
to start from scratch i'm just going to
type
npm init and i'm going to accept
just about all of this so what what's
happened now i've created a package.json
simple enough okay so i've already
generated some metadata there just from
doing npm init so what i'm going to do
now
is i'm going to install rave
of course that's what i'm going to do
and
oh not bad everybody stop checking text
messages okay
all right and uh for fun i'm going to
install
an additional rave extension that allows
you to load
text through the module loader all right
and let's see
okay so i'm just opening up my favorite
editor
and you can see that you know i've
generated some metadata here rave and
rave load text are now
in here and either these are now
discoverable
by rave
okay and i'm going to quickly create an
index.html
and i'm going to give it a one-liner
okay so that's it and
i'm going to create a main.js if you
noticed very quickly i typed in main.js
when i was doing npm
init and asked me what the name of the
main entry point would be
so i'm creating something there and now
if i
i am just going to serve this folder
under port 8082 that's what i'm going to
do
and and it did not work
of course all right let me just see
what's going on here
i have a feeling that chrome is lying to
me here
let's try this 83.
i'm used to um yes
i'm used to an editor that i lied this
is not my favorite editor i'm used to an
editor that
auto saves okay
all right so console and yes we have a
yay
ignore those four fours for now i'll
show you how to get rid of those okay
all right so um
not that interesting but that's that's
the startup experience i'll show you a
more sophisticated application let's see
okay so
and let's see i am going to attempt to
pull something down as a tar file here
let's see how this goes
and it worked
all right so i'm going to install a
starter package here
okay so if you're watching this is
installing a few things
i installed a rave angular starter
package so
and if we look here you can see that
we've installed a couple things bower
angular and ravelo
json but you can also see that we've got
some other things that
transitively got installed
and we've got a minimal index.html here
and a minimal boot.js file which is just
a bootloader
and minimal main which is this is a
common js formatted
file that is actually bootstrapping
angular
and if i come over to the browser here
and let's see
let's do this on port 8082. the reason
i'm using different ports is because i
had some problems with
with chrome caching aggressively and or
my web server i haven't figured out
which one it is okay so
so
let's try this one
here we go okay so now we have an
angular application running
and
i'm going to switch over to one more
application here and this application
is definitely more sophisticated than
than the other ones
it's currently running on port 8081 so
it's right here it's just simple to do's
application
i can add some to-do's it's
communicating with
over web sockets to another port on on
this machine
but let's take a look at it and there's
index.html here and let's say you know
i've got a
you know just quickly look here it's
just it's just a very simple
mvc type application but let's say i
decide that
i want to incorporate css into
my build process so i'm going to stop
using link elements and instead i'm
going to pull that in
through through my build and and and
build bundle that actually into the
javascript so i can do that
um because i've installed this uh rave
load css
rave extension and now i can do things
like
require my css as if it were a module
and so i just
just switched over to that let's see
remember to save again
and i reload over here and so now
take a look at the elements here and you
can see that this is commented out but
we still have the css
because um the css got injected at
runtime and
and uh this all all gets uh so the css
would actually get bundled into the
javascript in this case and so
that's just an example of one way that
you can
extend the loader extend the
capabilities just by installing a
package
so
so basically it's it's right here
because because i installed it and i did
bower install
dash dash save it's available there and
and rave can discover it and just know
what to do with it
so okay so
so where is rave today uh right now
we're able to
uh load bauer use bauer and npm to pull
down packages
we're able to load amd style or node
style
you know common js packages
um we can we can load text files uh
through the loader css json we've got a
whole suite of cujo js
extensions out there and we're very
close to having
the no configuration build story uh
working as well like i said probably
about four to six weeks
and that'll be done uh also coming very
soon es6 module syntax
uh be able to write you know in a very
clean import export
type module syntax uh it's probably
still early because
you know the until browsers have
implemented that it's subject to change
but
we'll be um we'll be offering it anyways
for you
daredevils um and then you know we're
working on some other things like
angular
and and integration even deeper that's
actually uh we actually actually have
that started too
so so i'm going to cut it off there
i've got plenty more to show you guys if
anybody's interested come see me i can i
can definitely show you some more stuff
and um any questions right now i think
we have a time for
a question or two if anybody has a
question anyone
yes
sorry
yes it will integrate integrate with uh
grails and or spring
um how that works and how much isn't
that is in rave and how much that of
that goes into grails in spring uh
i'm not 100
okay so so so that's a good question you
know like
grails people aren't gonna wanna they're
not gonna understand why do i have to go
install node in order to build an app
right
so so that's a choice and um
we've been thinking about about that a
lot actually
and it's it becomes more obvious when
you think of the front end as a separate
application
right um but that's why i'm also saying
that
you know we also might incorporate some
of that into the the spring and the
grail side as well
so for spring web jars came up but the
way that web jars is implemented
it it can't work with this sophisticated
level of
of stuff was really meant for for
browser globals
and there's some real nasty hacks in
there for required js
but we're also thinking about talking to
them to see if they can overhaul web
jars but
right
right so use grails instead of node and
so yeah
um definitely interested in that that's
that feels like
a larger task right now because like i
said we want to leverage gulp and grunt
first and use the
use the tools that javascript developers
are using instead of just
you know instead of what grails guys are
using so but but definitely
we've been talking about it a lot and so
we do want to do it it's just not going
to be the first thing
all right thanks guys
so
you